die Bundestagsvizepräsidentin wird
mutmaßlich jetzt gleich weitere
Tagesordnungspunkte aufrufen
gegebenenfalls auch schon
Abstimmungsergebnisse nein wir sie ruft
direkt schon das Krankenhaus Pflege
entlastungsgesetz auf
später dann am Nachmittag noch der
Energie Soli aber das krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz das ist ein
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung da
geht es um
pflegepersonalbemessung im Krankenhaus
sowie zur Anpassung weitere Regelungen
im Krankenhaus gewesen und in der
Digitalisierung auch das immer ein ganz
kleines Reizwort wenn es um Deutschland
geht und auch das deutsche
Gesundheitswesen aber das wäre Rezept
scheint ja jetzt am Horizont dann doch
erkennbar das hat der
Bundesgesundheitsminister der übrigens
auch schon Platz genommen hat gestern
noch einmal in den Raum gestellt hier
also geht es jetzt um die zweite und
dritte Lesung es gibt auch noch Anträge
von Linksfraktion und von der
afd-fraktion aber ganz grundsätzlich
geht es darum im Krankenhaus und im
Gesundheit Wesen bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen zu erreichen sie
haben alle durchaus auch diese Engpässe
in den Medien wahrgenommen die wir jetzt
zum Beispiel in diesen bevorstehenden
Winter im Bereich der Kinderkliniken
haben da soll jetzt insbesondere bei der
Pflege das ist immer ein Problem
nachgebessert werden und zwar relativ
schnell der Bundesgesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach am Pult
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit dem heute vorgelegten
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz
beginnt nichts weniger als eine
Revolution in der Art und Weise wie wir
Krankenhausplanung gestalten und wie die
Versorgung in Krankenhäusern stattfinden
soll worum geht es
wir haben
das Gleichgewicht verloren zwischen
Medizin und Ökonomie und es wird derzeit
im Krankenhaussektor in Deutschland zu
viel bestimmt durch Belange der Ökonomie
die medizinischen Aspekte sind in den
Hintergrund rückt dieses Gleichgewicht
muss neu justiert werden und
insbesondere müssen wir auch darüber
nachdenken wie das System der
Fallpauschalen überwunden werden kann
war durch die fahrpauschale ist es jetzt
so dass eine Qualität die minderwertig
ist genauso bezahlt wird wie eine
besonders hochwertige Qualität immer die
gleiche pauschale und es gibt einen
massiven Anreiz auch viele pauschalen
abzubrechen daher ist das System ein
System welches billig und Menge betont
statt Qualität und Angemessenheit und
das muss neue justiert werden wir können
im Krankenhaussektor nicht mit den
gleichen Regeln vorgehen wie zum
Beispiel Lidl Lebensmittel verkauft die
muss die Qualität und die medizinischen
Aspekte müssen wieder in den Vordergrund
rücken und diese revol beginnt mit dem
heutigen Gesetz
wenn ein solches wahlpauschalensystem so
eingeführt wird wie wir es gemacht haben
als 100 Prozent Ansatz dann bleiben die
Bereiche zurück wo man keine Gewinne
machen kann das gilt insbesondere für
die Pflege das geht zum Beispiel für die
Kinderheilkunde das gilt aber auch für
die Geburtshilfe daher fangen wir mit
diesem Bereichen an um dort sozusagen
das neue Gleichgewicht aufzubauen es
darf nicht sein es darf nicht länger
sein das auf dem Rücken von Kindern
Pflegekräften und Hebammen Gewinne
gemacht werden und das medizinische
zurückdrängt das wollen wir nicht
weiterhin nehmen
daher hat dieses Gesetz fünf
Schwerpunkte im Bereich Krankenhaus zum
einen die Pflege dort wird dokumentiert
wie ist eigentlich die Pflegesituation
auf den Stationen wo es eine
Unterdeckung gibt können mehr und müssen
mehr Pflegekräfte eingestellt werden und
die Arbeit übernehmen der zweite Punkt
ist eigentlich aus meiner Sicht fast der
wichtigste in den Kinderkliniken haben
wir eine enorme not das war mir schon
klar bevor ich überhaupt Minister wurde
daher war es eine meiner ersten
Initiativen dass wir die Fallpauschalen
in der Kinderheilkunde dass wir die
stark zurücknehmen in einem Korridor von
80 bis 100 Prozent bekommen jetzt die
Kinderkliniken das gleiche Geld egal wie
viele Fälle sie abbrechen so dass da
dieser Hamsterrad Effekt sofort
herausgenommen ist stellen wir uns vor
wir hätten das nicht gemacht wir
beschließen ja heute dieses Gesetz wir
haben Monate daran gearbeitet es war es
ist jetzt dringend notwendig wir
brauchen das Geld unmittelbar ab dem
ersten Januar 300 Millionen Euro als
sofort für die Kinderkliniken so dass
die Kinder aus diesem Hamsterrad
herauskommen ich möchte mich an dieser
Stelle auch ausdrücklich bedanken bei
den Pflegekräften und den Ärzten und
Ärzten die jetzt diese schwere
rsv-epidemie in Deutschland behandeln
sie leisten großartiges sie können sich
unsere Unterstützung hier voll sicher
sein wir werden alles tun um sie durch
diese schwierige Krise zu bringen das zu
schulden wir den Pflegekräften und den
Ärzten aber in aller erster Linie den
Kindern wir werden nichts unterlassen
wir werden nichts unterlassen was wir
den Kindern beten können wir sind hier
in der Pflicht und genauso gehen wir
auch in der Geburtshilfe vor es wird
dort Zuschläge geben und was auch
wichtig ist Hebammen werden zu 100%
außerhalb des Budgets erstattet jede
Hebamme die im Krankenhaus arbeite für
voll finanziert die stehen da den
Pflegekräften gleich es ist auch dort
müssen wir mehr investieren dazukommen
tagesstationäre versorg das Angebote
Hybrid ist das mehr ambulant gemacht
werden kann mehr ambulante Versorgung
ist auch für die Pflege wichtig denn
jede Leistung die ambulant gemacht
werden kann selbst Pflegekräfte frei
jede Übernachtung den ich notwendig ist
setzt Nachtdienste und schichtenfrei das
heißt auch diese Maßnahmen sind zentral
um eine verbesserte Versorgung in der
Pflege hinzubekommen daher ein großes
Gesetz dieses Gesetz hat auch nur ein
paar Grundlagen in der Digitalisierung
und das werden meine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nachher erläutern ich muss mich
hier kurz fassen wir setzen damit auch
also in Gang ein Prozess dass die
elektronische Patientenakte in
Deutschland genutzt werden kann im
großen und ganzen ein wichtiges Gesetz
und bereits in der nächsten Woche werden
wir dann die nächsten Schritte
vorstellen mit der Expertenkommission
Krankenhaus der Bundesregierung wir
arbeiten hier mit hoher Taktzahlen mit
großem Tempo daher möchte ich auch allen
Abgeordneten die diese schnelle Taktzahl
mitgehen aber auch den Mitarbeitern im
Haus ganz herzlich danken ich weiß dass
ich Ihnen auch viel abverlange wir sind
im hohen Tempo unterwegs aber es wird
eine gute Qualität geliefert das ist
osmaner Sicht eine gute Zeit für die
Entwicklung des Krankenhaus ich danke
Ihnen für die Zusammenarbeit und für die
Unterstützung bitte stimmen Sie diesem
wichtigen Gesetz heute zu
das plädoy jedes
Bundesgesundheitsministers Karl
Lauterbach für das Gesetz das hier ein
zweiter und dritter Lesung vorliegt
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz
gleichzeitig auch nochmal der Hinweis
auf den starken Tempo was man anlegen
möchte weil bestimmte Regelung bereits
im ersten Januar kommen sollen kinosa
geht jetzt der gesundheitspolitische
Sprecher der Unionsfraktion und Kollegen
im Grunde ist das was im Gesetz steht ja
wirklich viele Debatten Wert sehr sehr
viele Debatten sogar aber ich will genau
das machen was der Minister auch hier
gemacht hat ich will darüber reden was
sehr interessant ist was eben nicht im
Gesetz steht und das was sie lieber Herr
Minister gemacht haben war eben darüber
zu reden was nicht im Gesetz steht und
wir haben ja ein riesen Problem hier
haben wir haben ein Problem was tausende
von Menschen im Land wirklich umtreibt
was Kliniken umtreibt was Einrichtungen
umtreibt worüber wirklich seit Monaten
alle sprechen wo sie kein Wort verloren
haben das ist quasi der Elefant der hier
im Raum steht oder das Mammut im
Plenarsaal es geht um die energiehilfen
wir haben Kliniken wir haben
Einrichtungen wir haben
Pflegeinstitutionen die warten auf diese
energiepreishilfen
Inflationsausgleich die wissen nicht wie
sie jetzt im Dezember die Löhne bezahlen
sollen die wissen nicht wie sie es
Weihnachtsgeld bezahlen sollen kein Wort
davon kein Wort wie das der bezahlt wird
und da hätten wir mehr erwartet liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und jetzt jetzt will ich auch mal auf
dieses krankenhauspflege
entlassungsgesetz eingehen das ist ja
schön und gut wenn sie sagen sie wollen
mit diesen krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz Pflege entlasten auch
in den Häusern das Problem ist nur sie
tun genau das Gegenteil das ist ein
Krankenhaus pflegebelastungsgesetz und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich sage
Ihnen auch warum dieses Gesetz wird
weder die Krankenhäuser entlasten das
Gesetz bringt vor allem Unklarheit und
neue Belastung ich mache Ihnen das auch
ganz konkret an Beispielen fest Beispiel
1 Pflegepersonal Bemessung das klingt ja
alles ganz gut
pflegepersonalbemessung
Bedarfsermittlung Bemessung aber erstens
ist kommt viel zu spät 2025 wenn es
kommen soll und zweitens genau mit
diesen starren Pflegepersonal
Bemessungskriterien setzen Sie neue
Daumenschrauben an neue Daumenschrauben
für die Kolleginnen und Kollegen die in
der Pflege Arbeit also im Grunde nichts
was vor Ort hilft liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Beispiel 2
tagesbehandlung das hört sich natürlich
alles sehr romantisch an wenn man sagt
wir machen jetzt tagesbehandlung dann
kann man als Patient was man ja erstmal
gar nicht schlecht findet nach der
Behandlung abends nach Hause gehen aber
die Fragen die damit zusammenhängen also
die Frage der Haftung die Frage der
Umsetzung der Frage der Mobilität was
ist mit Patienten Patienten die
Komplikation zu Hause haben das ist
überhaupt nicht geklärt das ist genau
das was in die Krankenhäuser was in die
Einrichtung sagen kein Wort im Gesetz
darüber
Beispiel 3
das ist ja genau das bemerkenswerte der
Minister hat sich hier wieder
hingestellt und hat gesagt er wolle dass
die AG das System der Fallpauschalen
überwinden dann hätte ich mir zumindest
gewünscht dass ihr hier ganz konkret
sagt wie sieht die Alternative aus das
hat er hier nicht getan und deshalb
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
Sie uns doch an diesem System arbeiten
es ist ja im Grunde das skurrile dass
der Vater der Fallpauschalen also
derjenige der sie mit entwickelt hat rot
grün hat diese Fallpauschalen ins Leben
gerufen sich jetzt hinstellt und sagt na
ja ist dumm gelaufen ist nicht mehr in
Ordnung wir machen was neues und
insofern sagen Sie was Sie Neues machen
wollen arbeiten Sie mit uns daran dass
wir nachjustieren dass wir mit höheren
vorhalte Kosten arbeiten dass wir
vielleicht Fallpauschalen die nicht
auskömmlich sind auch nachjustieren oder
sagen Sie welche Alternative aber nein
sie haben keinen Plan A sie haben keinen
Plan B und das was hier vorgestellt wird
ist überhaupt nichts
unterm Strich
unterm Strich ist dieses Gesetz
kein Krankenhaus entlastungsgesetz ist
ein krankenhausbelastungsgesetz wir
werden die Gesetze deshalb nicht
zustimmen oder Bemerkung der Kollegin
Vogler selbstverständlich
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin vielen Dank
Herr Kollege dass sie meine Frage
beziehungsweise zwischen Bemerkung
zulassen und zum einen frage ich mich ja
welche
Prinz das Dornröschen Union wachgeküsst
hat bei der Umsetzung der PPR 20 und
warum sie in den letzten Jahren an
dieser Stelle geschlafen haben weil das
Instrument ja schon lange entwickelt
worden ist und wir immer wieder als
Linke drauf gedrängt haben das möglichst
schnell umzusetzen um die Beschäftigten
in den Krankenhäusern zu entlasten die
Patienten Patienten besser zu versorgen
als zweites möchte ich noch mal ein
Punkt ansprechen den sie in ihrer Rede
noch nicht angesprochen haben und das
ist diese fatale
das Fatale Einvernehmen das mit dem
Finanzministerium hergestellt werden
muss seitens des Gesundheitsministeriums
um überhaupt dieses
pflegeentlastungsgesetz in den
Krankenhäusern umzusetzen in allen ist
klar das wird Geld erfordern und wenn
aber Herr Lindner da sozusagen auf der
Leitung steht wird es schwer sein dieses
Geld zurückzuführen wir haben als Linke
das sehr sehr früh kritisiert vor vier
Wochen da schon einen entsprechenden
Änderungsantrag in den Virus eingebracht
und dem hätten sie ja zustimmen können
weil überraschenderweise am
Dienstagnachmittag um 15 Uhr also nicht
mal 24 Stunden vor der Ausschusssitzung
ging uns ein gleichlautender
Änderungsantrag der Unionsfraktion zu
dem wir natürlich zugestimmt haben aber
warum haben sie denn überhaupt
eingebracht sie hätten doch einfach dem
Änderungsantrag den die Linke im
Ausschuss eingebracht hat zustimmen
können dann hätten wir das gemeinsam
abgestimmt da hätten sie sich die Mühe
dieses Plagiats überhaupt nicht zu
machen brauchen
ja liebe Frau Kollegin Vogler vielen
Dank für die Frage das gibt mir noch mal
Möglichkeit auch darauf hinzuweisen dass
nicht nur unser Antrag nicht nur besser
war sondern dass er auch weitergehen war
und deshalb haben wir natürlich den
eigenen Antrag gestellt und zum anderen
auch zugestimmt und das gibt mir auch
die Möglichkeit noch mal darauf
hinzuweisen dass das ja wirkt das
Oppositionsarbeit wirkt auch
Oppositionsarbeit von ihnen wenn ich da
beispielsweise an die Hebammen denke wir
haben ja bei den Hebammen das Problem
gehabt dass es darum ging dass diese
eben aus dem Pflege Budget ausgegliedert
werden sollten und insofern da haben wir
Anträge gestellt da haben wir ständig
auch Rabatt gemacht da hat die Kollegin
Emmi Zollner aus unserer Fraktion
federführen sich darum gekümmert und es
hat ja auch gewirkt ich weiß jetzt nicht
ob es an den 1,6 Millionen Menschen die
eine Petition unterschrieben haben
Gelegenheit oder an unseren Anträgen
also man sieht
Opposition wirkt aber weil sie hier in
Märchen Duktus sprechen ich meine wir
hätten uns auch gewünscht dass der
Frosch der ständige küsst wird ob das
jetzt Christian Lindner oder wer auch
immer ist mal zu einem Froschkönig oder
zu einem Prinzen wird aber es ist leider
nicht passiert und deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen darf ich noch
mal darauf hinweisen dieses Gesetz ist
ihnen überhaupt kein Gesetz was diesen
Anspruch gerecht wird dass es das was
wir kritisieren das ist auch das was sie
kritisieren und insofern sind wir uns ja
in der Opposition einig genauso wie mit
den meisten Akteuren auch im System und
diese Kritik die ja nicht nur von uns
als Opposition kommt sondern diese
Kritik kommt ja von nahezu allen
Akteuren das ist sind die Kliniken das
sind die Pflegeeinrichtungen das sind
sämtliche Einrichtungen nehmen Sie diese
Kritik ernst wischen Sie die nicht vom
Tisch und arbeiten sie konstruktiv mit
uns an Lösungen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und da wir ja da wir ja liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen am Sonntag den
zweiten Advent haben will ich nur noch
mal darauf hinweisen dass lateinische
Wort Advent bedeutet ja so viel wie
Ankunft in diesem Sinne erwarten wir als
Union die Ankunft ihrer Gesetze liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel aber
Gesetze die echte Entlastung für die
Kliniken die echte Entlastung für das
Pflegepersonal bringen in diesem Sinne
bleiben Sie am Ball schlagen sie was vor
sonst brennt hier nämlich bald der Baum
und das will keiner vielen Dank liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
[Applaus]
Fraktion im krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz zweite dritte Lesung
mal ein Blick auf die Regierungsbank an
dieser Stelle bietet sich mal an es ist
später Nachmittag ja die Kamera kann
ruhig ein bisschen schneller aufziehen
und wir haben einen Bundesminister und
drei Staatssekretärinnen und eine
Staatsministerin Hannas wünscht man sich
ein bisschen stärker die Präsenz weil
dies ist ein wichtiges Thema für
Deutschland und Jana stammen wird es
nochmal unterstreichen wer ist der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Grünen Fraktion auch nicht über Dinge
reden die nicht im Gesetz stehen oder
nicht auf der Tagesordnung stehen
sondern möchte mich auf den vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf beziehen
ich glaube
wenn wir uns die Situation aktuell
beispielsweise in den Kinderkliniken
anschauen ist die Situation auch zu
ernst über schräge Vergleiche oder
irgendwelche Witze zu reden sondern es
ist Zeit zu handeln und das tun wir mit
diesem Gesetz und zwar auf der vollen
Breite der Gesundheitsversorgung indem
wir sehr wichtigere Formen auf den Weg
bringen der Reihe nach zum einen ist es
so dass wir im Bereich der
Kinderkliniken die jetzt so unter Druck
stehen
wichtigere Formen auf den Weg bringen
die einerseits die Finanzierung
verbessern indem wir pro Jahr 300
Millionen zusätzlich in die Finanzierung
der Kinderkliniken stecken und
gleichzeitig eine wichtige
budgetgarantie auf den Weg bringen die
auskömmliche Finanzierung der
stationären kinderheilversorgung in
Deutschland sicherstellt zweitens sorgen
wir mit diesem Gesetz dafür durch die
Einführung spezieller
personalbemessungsinstrumente in der
Kinderkrankenpflege und nicht nur dort
dazu wird meine Kollegen Cordula Schulz
Asche gleich noch mehr sagen genau dafür
sorgen dass mehr Pflegepersonal in der
Kinderkrankenpflege aber auch auf den
Intensivstationen der Kinderklinik zur
Verfügung stehen wird ein wichtiger
Schritt der die Situation von Versorgung
verbittert drittens im Bereich der
Kinderheilkunde wir führen unter anderem
dort aber auch in anderen Bereichen eine
Verbesserung der telemedizinischen
beziehungsweise telekonseriarischen
Versorgung ein die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen spezialisierten Kinderkliniken
und Kliniken der Grundversorgung wird
verbessert Forderungen die diese Woche
noch von den intensivmedizinern erhoben
werden werden heute hier im Deutschen
Bundestag bereits umgesetzt im Bereich
der Geburtshilfe sorgen wir dafür dass
nicht nur eine bessere Finanzierung da
ist sondern dass Hebammen einerseits wie
bereits angesprochen vollständig aus dem
Pflege Budget finanziert werden und das
sei bereits angekündigt auch kurzfristig
vollständig auf die Personal
Untergrenzen der nach und
vorgeburtlichen Stationen in den
Krankenhäusern anrechnungsfähig eine
große Forderung der Verbände im Übrigen
ein Hinweis der auch aus der Union kam
den wir nicht beiseite geschoben haben
zugehört haben heute beschließen
umgesetzt wird die Versorgung verbessern
wird
der dritte wichtige Aspekt im Bereich
der Krankenhausversorgung Dinge die über
Jahre nur in Sonntagsreden genannt
wurden nämlich die ambulantisierung
stationärer Versorgung wird in zwei
wichtigen Bereichen mit der
tagesbehandlung und den sogenannten
hybrids auf den Weg gebracht das sorgt
dafür dass dort wo Übernachtung nicht
notwendig ist aber die Strukturen eines
Krankenhaus für Versorgung sinnvoll ist
endlich möglich ist die Mutter mit ihrem
Kind kann nach Behandlung am Tag sowohl
pflegerische und ärztlich abends nach
Hause gehen und muss nicht im
Mehrbettzimmer mit anderen Kindern und
anderen Eltern übernachten was die
Genesung nicht zuträglich sein muss und
ein wichtigen Baustein ist
beispielsweise in der Versorgung die uns
nach vorne bringt die Metallentfernung
nach einer komplizierten Bruch muss
nicht mehr im Krankenhaus durchgeführt
werden sondern kann bei gleicher
Vergütung möglicherweise zukünftig
ambulant zu besserer Qualität mit
niedrigen Risiken Rum wird das ist nicht
nur wer angekündigt das wird umgesetzt
auf diesem Weg ein wichtigere
formschritt den wir heute mit diesem
Gesetz nach vorne bringen und lassen Sie
mich
neben diesen wichtigen Reformen in der
Krankenhausversorgung auch noch etwas
zum digitalisierungsbereich sagen im
Unterschied zu Dingen die in der
vergangenen Legislatur immer wieder im
Mittelpunkt standen womit vielen
einzelreformen in einem wilden
Durcheinander immer Digitalisierung
propagiert aber in der Praxis auf Chaos
erzeugt wurde sorgen wir mit einer
digitalstrategie die zurzeit mit allen
Stakeholdern entwickelt wird für ein
strukturierten Prozess und bringen in
dem Gesetz heute in
mit dem Gesetz heute vereinfachte
Zugangsvoraussetzungen zur
elektronischen Patientenakte und anderen
wichtigen Strukturen der Telematik
Infrastruktur auf den Weg wie mit den
elektronischen Personalausweis und
anderen Dingen alles was hätte längst
passieren müssen um Digitalisierung und
Gesundheitswesen voranzubringen
im dritten und auch das sei gesagt ist
es so dass wir im Bereich der Pflege
durch maßgebliche Einführung der
Personalbemessung endlich das Wort
halten was aus den pflegeverbänden über
Jahre eingefordert wird eine
Personalbemessung die mit Sanktionen
verknüpft ist und deswegen Wirkung
entfaltet und die Arbeitsbedingungen von
pflegenden verbessert und nicht nur
Luftbuchungen erzeugt die am Ende in der
Versorgung keinen Unterschied macht also
hören Sie auf über Märchen zu reden
stimmen Sie diesen wichtigen Gesetz zu
vielen Dank es ist ein gutes Gesetz
auch Jana stammen mit einem Plädoyer für
dieses krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz einigen Hintergründen
zu thematischen Schwerpunkten unter
anderem eben ein neues Instrument zur
Personalbemessung soll auf den Weg
gebracht werden die jetzt nächste Redner
Thomas Dietz für die afd-fraktion Frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die krankenhauspflege in Deutschland
steht derzeit vor dem erschreckenden
Ergebnis der jahrelang Ignoranz der
herrschenden Politik gegenüber diesen
fundamentalen Bereich einer sozialen
Gesellschaft
bereits jetzt können notwendige
felgemaßnahmen oft nicht mit dem
gebotenen Aufwand durchgeführt werden
weil es an Zeit an Personal oder der
entsprechenden Ausbildung mangelt es
kommt zu einer impliziten Rationierung
die Feld am Patienten die Überwachung
der Patienten Gespräche mit Angehörigen
und eine korrekte Dokumentation sind
kaum noch angemessen umzusetzen die
eigentliche Pflegearbeit wird zunehmend
ausgehöhlt auch bei unserer
hochqualifizierten und gut ausgebildeten
Pflegekräfte Aufgaben übernehmen müssen
die sich auch durch anderes Personal
gewährleistet werden könnten die
Krankenschwester muss sich in den
Kranken kümmern und nicht um hohe und
bringedienst als Reinigungskraft oder
hauptberufliche dokumentationskraft
dienen
die daraus resultierende Unzufriedenheit
mündet immer wieder in der Flucht
qualifizierter Kräfte aus in anderer
Berufe das mehr als ungerechte Corona
Pflege Bundesgesetz bei deren viele
Mitarbeiter leer ausgingen also einen
weiteren Unmut im Pflege und
Krankenhausbereich geführt
ein Teufelskreis also da nicht
durchbrochen werden kann wenn sie die
Frage nicht beantworten können wie sie
mehr Personal akquirieren können
bei der Diskussion zum Gesetzentwurf kam
es im Ausschuss bei meinen Vortrag zu
einem das üblichen Zurufe vom längst
grünen Block und mehr Zuwanderung das
heißt um die Probleme in der
krankenhauspflege zu lösen brauchen wir
eine Ansicht von rot oder grün weiterer
Zuwanderung
aber das es ist ja genau ihre
psychologisches Problem Werte Kollegen
sie glauben mit Zuwanderung all die
Probleme lösen zu können die sich in
Deutschland in den letzten Jahrzehnten
inzwischen zu einem Kilimandscharo
aufgetürmt haben
Deutschland ist längst kein attraktives
Zuwanderungsland für ausländische
Fachkräfte mehr jetzt werde ich
dafür sind die Steuern und Abgaben hier
im Land viel zu hoch und die
Arbeitsbedingungen zu schlecht aber
Deutschland ist inzwischen das
attraktivste Zuwanderungsland vor
sozialflüchtlinge
unsere europäischen Nachbarn und Freunde
finden inzwischen Sonderzüge und diese
Menschen frei Haus zu bringen Städte und
Landkreise brechen gerade unter diesem
Ansturm zusammen und nun müssen wir
feststellen dass wir als diesen
Potenzial von zwei bis drei Millionen
Zuwanderung der letzten Jahre noch nicht
einmal genügend Fachkräfte für die
Sortierung der Koffer in der Flughäfen
gewinnen könnten
geschweige denn ausgebildete
Pflegekräfte mit den absolut
unverzichtbaren Sprachkenntnissen die
dazu gehören
ich möchte ja explizit die bundesweite
Studie ich pflege wieder wenn
der Arbeitnehmerkammer Bremen von April
2022 und mehr als 12.000 Befragten
erwähnen diese besagt mindestens 300.000
vollzeitpflegekräfte Stunden in
Deutschland durch Rückkehr in dem Beruf
oder Aufstockung der Arbeitszeit
zusätzlich zur Verfügung sofern sich die
Arbeitsbedingungen in der Pflege
verbessern würden
sie haben es geschafft in einer Zeit das
ohnehin schon an personalmangelt
tausende durch die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht aus dem Beruf zu nötigen und
andere abzuschrecken in diesem Bereich
tätig zu werden weiterhin besteht ein
einstellungsstau weil die rechtswidrige
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht noch
bis Ende des Jahres läuft und nicht
vorher ausgesetzt wurde wenn sie jetzt
nicht das
gesundheits-zu vorbildliches
Gesundheitswesen wie in Deutschland so
sehr schwer bestätigt werden konnte
werden Sie deshalb Ihre Aufgabe gerecht
und nehmen Sie mehr Geld und
Verantwortung für unsere
Gesundheitssystem in die Hand vielen
Dank
die Redebeitrag von Thomas Dietze für
die AFD sitzt er im Gesundheitsausschuss
des Deutschen Bundestages nächste
Rednerin in dieser Debatte angekündigt
von der FDP-Fraktion die
pflegepolitische Sprecherin Nicole
westlich auf dem Weg zum Pult zweite
dritte Lesung Krankenhaus
pflegeentlastungsgesetz
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Dietz sie haben hier
wunderbar die AFD Ideologie abgearbeitet
aber ich habe keinen einzigen
Lösungsvorschlag gehört
heute ist ein guter Tag für die Pflege
in Deutschland denn mit diesem Gesetz
senden wir das lang ersehnte Signal für
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen in unseren
Kliniken wir bringen die PPR 2.0 endlich
auf den Weg als lernendes System soll
sie uns zeigen wie die
Personalausstattung aussehen soll um
eine optimale Patientenversorgung zu
erreichen dabei stellen wir die
Begleitung durch die Pflegewissenschaft
sicher
mittelfristig soll dies auch für die
Intensivstation und die
Notfallambulanzen gelten die
Ausnahmeklausel für Unikliniken mit
entlastungstarifverträgen ist gestrichen
so dass nun die Pflegenden in allen
Häusern von den Verbesserungen
profitieren werden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
stärken die Pflege wir stärken aber auch
die Geburtshilfe Hebammen sind weiterhin
im pflegebudget enthalten wir
korrigieren damit einen Fehler künftig
können die Hebammen sogar voll
angerechnet werden so dass die Kliniken
Sie flexibel einsetzen können außerdem
erhalten die Länder zusätzliche Gelder
damit die Kliniken ihre Vorhaltekosten
für die Geburtshilfe abfedern können ich
bin den hebammenverbänden sehr dankbar
dass sie öffentlich ihre Stimme erhoben
haben und ich danke Michelle Franco und
begrüße Sie ganz Herzlich hier auf der
Tribüne sie ist die Initiatorin der
Petition die inzwischen 1,6 Millionen
Unterschriften hat
vielen Dank Frau Franke
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
fortschrittskoalition will die
Sektorengrenzen überwinden und mehr
ambulantisierung der Grundsatz ambulant
vor stationär muss wieder mit Leben
erfüllt werden aus Sicht der Freien
Demokraten ist es richtig dass sie
Selbstverwaltung die Chance bekommt den
zugehörigen Leistungskatalog bis zum
Frühjahr selbst zu vereinbaren wir
machen aber deutlich dass die Vergütung
sich nur auf die krankenhausleistung
bezieht
wahlärztliche Leistungen von Arzt und
Krankenhaus bleiben daneben abrechenbar
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Gesundheitsversorgung der Zukunft geht
nicht ohne digitale Transformation wer
erleichtern den Zugang zur
Telematik-Infrastruktur die Hürden
hierfür waren bislang derartig hoch das
kaum jemand die elektronische
Patientenakte nutzte wir sorgen dafür
dass Versicherte künftig
eigenverantwortlich über Ihre Daten
entscheiden können und die Ehepaar
endlich Fahrt aufnehmen kann
wir Freien Demokraten stehen auch
weiterhin für den Datenschutz das ist
klar er darf jedoch nicht jeglichen
Fortschritt blockieren
Fortschritt sichern wir nur dann wenn
digitale Lösungen auch von den Menschen
genutzt werden können die
fortschrittskoalition sichert mit diesem
Gesetz den Datenschutz anders als
bislang stellen wir dabei die
Nutzerfreundlichkeit jedoch nicht mehr
hinten an
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen durch das
grassierende RS-Virus erleben wir
aktuell dramatische Situationen auf den
Kinderstationen der Minister hat es
beschrieben nun recht sich dass die
Politik die Pädiatrie jahrelang so
schräglich vernachlässigt hat
auch die Kinderklinik in Sankt Augustin
in meinem Wahlkreis muss immer wieder um
ihr Überleben kämpfen obwohl sie für die
pädiatrische Versorgung über unsere
Region hinaus hochgeschätzt wird ob
corona-impfung für Kinder oder die
Versorgung junger ukrainischer
Kriegsopfer die großartige Arbeit konnte
ich bei einem Praktikum im Sommer selbst
kennenlernen ich habe allerdings auch
die Schwierigkeiten gesehen mit denen
unsere Kinderkliniken zu kämpfen haben
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass wir hier
nun endlich entgegenwirken
wir müssen das weiter im Blick behalten
denn kinder sind keine kleinen
Erwachsenen sie brauchen unsere
besondere Fürsorge wir werden weiterhin
die Kinderkliniken zielgenau
unterstützen
mit dem krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz geht die Ampel ein
entscheidendes Problem in der Pflege an
doch nicht nur dort Geburtshilfe
Pädiatrie Digitalisierung
ambulantisierung wir machen uns auf den
Weg
unterstützen Sie uns dabei und stimmen
Sie diesem Gesetz zu vielen Dank
der Gesetzentwurf hat tatsächlich im
Gesundheitsausschuss 32 Änderungsanträge
dass da mal in dieser Woche bekommen die
tatsächlich auch eingearbeitet wurden
und jetzt haben wir am Pult für die
Linksfraktion artisch geringer bei ihrer
Rede gehört Herr Lauterbach sie sprechen
tatsächlich von einer Revolution ich bin
schon spannend wenn die Union innerhalb
von zwei Tagen einen
entschließungsantragschaft der sie in
ihre Revolution links überholt entweder
mein politischer Kompass ist völlig
verdorben oder das wäre ein ganz ganz
sanftes Reförmchen passiert durchsetzen
wollen warum
weil sie ihre eigenen Versprechen nicht
einhalten Herr Lauterbach versprochen im
Koalitionsvertrag pflegepersonalregelung
2.0 eine gute Idee um die Pflegekräfte
nicht mehr in solchen Stress zu bringen
und um die Menschen in den
Krankenhäusern endlich zu einer guten
Pflege zu bringen erdacht und erprobt
von Verdi
DKG und Pflegerat und das wird mit
diesem Gesetz von ihnen eben nicht
eingeführt sie verschieben die genaue
Umsetzung einer Personalbemessung ins
Ministerium und die verdient in dem
Bereich der Kollege Franken halt keinen
wirklichen vertrauen sie selbst haben
gesagt dass die PBR 2.0 eben nicht
gewollt ist und ich gebe Ihnen noch eine
Möglichkeit sie haben noch heute die
Möglichkeit unserem Antrag zuzustimmen
der die Umsetzung der
pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 genau
einfordert wenn sie dem heutigen stimmen
dann kann ich ihnen Glauben schenken
ansonsten glaube ich ihnen eben nicht
dass die Pflegepersonal Bewegung 2.0
eingeführt ist und noch absurder ist es
dass die Umsetzung unter dem Vorbehalt
des Finanzministers steht sie reden von
Revolution und Lindner ist der
steuermacht Liebe Koalition das ist doch
wirklich lächerlich die Konservativen
und wir haben den Antrag gestellt dass
das aus dem Gesetz gestrichen wird und
sie haben das verhindert das ist doch
absurd absurd für die Pflegekräfte und
absurde für die Patientin sie haben im
Koalitionsvertrag versprochen
kurzfristiger auskömmliche Finanzierung
der Kinder und Jugendmedizin Lauterbach
behauptet die Fallpauschalen zu
überwinden das Versprechen ist gebrochen
die bleiben vollständig in Kraft und die
bisschen mehr als 10% zusätzlich Erlöse
werden anhand der Fallpauschalen
Gießkanne für Spezialkliniken eben mehr
und für mit Nachteilen für die
Grundversorgung ausgeschüttet obwohl die
jetzt gerade im letzten Tagen
geschrieben hat sie haben versprochenen
Koalitionsvertrag kurzfristig
auskömmliche auskömmliche Finanzierung
der Geburtshilfe Versprechen gebrochen
warum weil die erste Version des
antragsvorsah dass weniger als 10% aller
Kreissäle von diesem Zuschuss
profitieren sollten nun haben sie das
Geld nicht erhöht verteilen aber auf
alle Kreissäle ich glaube man muss den
Dreisatz nicht allzu gut können um zu
verstehen dass das wohl nicht
ausreichend wird aber es gibt einen
Lichtblick in dem Gesetz
sehr geehrter die Herausnahme der
Hebammen aus den Fallpauschalen das ist
bedarfsgerecht aber das war nicht ihr
Plan im Gegenteil sie hatten das erstmal
rausgenommen und den Druck der
Berufsgruppe den Druck der Patente die
heute hier ist der ist es zu verdanken
dass dieses wieder reinkämpfen können
und das sollten wir uns als Beispiel
nehmen denn die Revolution entstehen
eben nicht in den Palästen sondern die
entstehen da draußen wenn die anderen
Berufsgruppen auch wirklich den Druck
aufbauen dann wird es für Folgen haben
für alle Berufsgruppen wenn wir die
Fallpauschalen wenn wir die
Berufsgruppen aus dem Partner schauen
rausnehmen ich komme zum Schluss dann
werden wir einen richtigen Erfolg
schaffen ich wünsche uns allen viel
Erfolg die Pflege wirklich zu verbessern
die Koalition hat das nicht geschafft
vielen Dank
in der Debatte war das
artischa für die
Linksfraktion ist folgt jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion Christoph Christos pantasis
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der Tat
heute ist ein guter Tag für die Pflege
der mit dem hier vorliegenden
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz
werden wir heute dem Kern nach die
Pflegekräfte in Krankenhäusern durch ein
personalbemessungsinstrument nachhaltig
entlassen heute ist allerdings auch ein
guter Tag für unsere Krankenhäuser
Psyche stellen wir heute nach acht
berichterstattergesprächen und insgesamt
32 Änderungsanträgen auch die ersten
Weichen für eine stabile moderne und
bedarfsgerechte Krankenhausversorgung
damit setzen wir einen zentrales
versprechen unseres Koalitionsvertrages
um kurzfristig für eine auskömmliche
bedarfsgerechte Finanzierung der
Pädiatrie und geburtshälfte zu sorgen
und werden mehr Fortschritt waren
mit diesem Gesetz leiten wir längst
überfällige Strukturreform ein deren
Versäumnis wie heute die Kollegen haben
es vorhin auch gesagt täglich in unseren
Kliniken sehen können und greifen damit
auf die Empfehlungen der
Regierungskommission zurück im Bereich
der Pädiatrie stellen wir Krankenhäusern
in den kommenden zwei Jahren zu
Behandlung von Kindern und Jugendlichen
zusätzliche Mittel in Höhe von 300
Millionen Euro zur Verfügung wobei wir
im Rahmen einer Sonderregelung für
besondere Einrichtungen diese ebenfalls
einen Zuschlag erhalten werden auch im
Bereich der Geburtshilfe werden wir mit
den in den kommenden zwei Jahren mit
zusätzlichen Mitteln in Höhe von
insgesamt 240 Millionen Euro die über
den Königsteiner Schlüssel an die
Bundesländer verteilt werden für eine
kurzfristige Stabilisierung sorgen dabei
knüpfen wir die Förderung an
Voraussetzungen wie die Vorhaltung einer
Pädiatrie einer Neonatologie der
Geburtenzahl der im Anzahl vaginaler
geboten sowie einer Hebammenpraxis
Ausbildung als Vater junger Zwillinge
weiß ich um die wertvolle Arbeit von
Hebammen
mit dem hier vorliegenden Gesetz tragen
wir dieser auch Rechnung in dem ihre
Refinanzierung über das pflegebudget in
der stationären Versorgung auch über das
Jahr 2025 hinaus gesichert ist
die fortschrittskoalition will die
ambulantisierung bislang unnötiger
stationär erbrachterleistungen fördern
und wird mit diesem Gesetz neben der
neuen tagesstationären Behandlungsform
ab April kommenden Jahres auch eine
sektorengleiche Vergütung für geeignete
Leistungen durch sogenannte
hybrid-stationären Behandlung entlasten
wir Pflegekräfte durch wegfallen nicht
notwendiger Übernachtungen im Leitsatz
der deutschen Gesundheitspolitik
ambulant vor stationär sehen wir ein
erhebliches konsolidierungspotenzial und
wollen diesen Prozess entschieden weiter
vorantreiben
und entsprechend den Vorgaben des GBA
werden wir dabei Transportkosten
erstatten denn Reformmaßnahmen dürfen
nicht auf dem Rücken der Schwächsten
ausgetragen werden ich fasse daher als
Berichterstatter meiner Fraktion
abschließend zusammen mit dem heutigen
Tag leiten wir den überfälligen
strukturellen Reformprozess im
Gesundheitssektor ein und sind
entschlossen das Jahr 2023 zum
reformjahr für den Krankenhaussektor zu
machen sie sehen als
fortschrittskoalition kündigen wir den
Fortschritt nicht nur an wir wagen ihn
und leiten hier und heute mit diesem
Gesetz entschieden ein herzlichen Dank
damit liegt die Latte hoch 2023 also das
reformjahr für das deutsche
Gesundheitswesen mal schauen wie Stefan
pilsinger von der optionsfraktion darauf
reagiert er ist Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss und Sprecher für
Gesundheit der CSU Landesgruppe frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren Herr
Lauterbach wer nicht komplett Realität
fremd ist der bekommt von den
Beschäftigten im Krankenhaus zu ihrem
Gesetz gesagt gut gemeint ist noch lange
nicht gut gemacht denn das Problem wird
damit in der Praxis einfach nicht gelöst
das grundsätzliche Problem ist
eigentlich allen klar wir haben zu
wenige Pflegekräfte in Deutschland
aktuell fehlen uns etwa 200.000
Pflegekräfte und 2013 könnten nur schon
etwa 500.000 Pflegekräfte sein wenn wir
nicht umgehend handeln und unsere
Pflegekräfte entlasten dann fahren wir
unser Gesundheitssystem absehbar
komplett gegen die Wand deshalb müssen
wir die Pflegepersonal Regelung 20 die
von der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft
vom deutschen pflegerad entwickelt und
hinreichender erprobt worden ist jetzt
einführen was wir nicht brauchen ist
eine ewige neuerprobung mit ziellosen
Diskussionen wir benötigen auch eine
auskömmliche Finanzierung der Pflege es
kann doch nicht sein dass es zukünftig
ein neues personalbemessungsinstrument
das entscheidet wie viel Personal in den
einzelnen Fachabteilungen eingesetzt
werden muss nur mit Zustimmung des
Bundesfinanzministeriums eingeführt
werden darf jeder vernünftige Mensch
fragt sich doch da was versteht
eigentlich Christian Lindner davon wie
viel Personal auf einer Intensivstation
eingesetzt werden soll das ist doch
völlig absurd das ist Pflege nach
Kassenlage
auch der von Ihnen in einer Nacht und
debelaktion eingeführte Änderungsantrag
der die Bezahlung zwischen privat und
gesetzlich Versicherten eingleicht führt
dazu dass nun ein Großteil der Ärzte
sagt das ist der Einstieg in die
Bürgerversicherung und liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der FDP dass sie das
mitmachen ist wirklich schlimm
[Applaus]
entweder sie haben ihre letzten
gesundheitspolitischen Grundsätze damit
komplett über Bord geworfen deshalb
haben wir in unserem
Entschließungsantrag klare Forderung wir
wollen das Pflegepersonal entlasten und
zwar durch eine sofortige Einführung der
hinreichenden erprobten
pflegepersonalregelung 20 was wir nicht
wollen sind endlose neuerprobung und die
Ente Diskussion das bringt am Ende
niemanden weiter wir wollen eine
auskömmliche Finanzierung eine
hochwertigen Pflege und nicht eine
Pflege nach lindenergnaden und wir
wollen
Freiberuflichkeit und keine reine
Staatsmedizin doch ein Einstieg in die
Bürgerversicherung durch die Hintertüre
mit unseren Maßnahmen helfen wir dem
Pflegepersonal praktisch und nicht nur
theoretisch deshalb bitte ich Sie heute
um Zustimmung zu unserem Änderungsantrag
vielen Dank
stefan pilsinger war das für die
Unionsfraktion also das Gesundheitswesen
das ja in der letzten Legislaturperiode
von der Union ganz konkret von der CDU
verantwortlich wurde jetzt also in der
Debatte Cordula Schulze Asche von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und der ausdrücklich Verdi dem deutschen
Pflegerat und der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft für die
Entwicklung dieses Instruments der PPR
2.0 der Personalbemessung im Krankenhaus
die wir jetzt schnell einführen und
gleichzeitig damit beginnen
wissenschaftlich weiterzuentwickeln weil
die bisherige Form nicht detailliert
genug ist wir werden uns daran machen
einen vernünftiges Instrument zu haben
um die Pflege die professionelle Pflege
im Krankenhaus abzubilden meine Damen
und Herren und wir werden ja besondere
Schutzbedürftigkeit von Kindern endlich
gerecht das wird auch eine
Personalbemessung für Kinder geben und
das ist längst überfällig meine Damen
und Herren das haben sie ihn Jahrzehnten
ihrer Verantwortung versäumt wir werden
auf den Intensivstation das Instrumente
Größe einführen und weiterentwickeln und
das ist längst überfällig denn wir
wissen welche prekären Situationen auf
den Intensivstationen stattfinden
und stellen die Frage ob sie eine Frage
Bemerkung des Kollegen Göppinger
selbstverständlich gerne
selbstverständlich das freut mich sehr
dass sie das Gesetz verständlich sehen
Frau kurze vielen Dank für die Zulassung
der Frage frau Präsidentin ich könnte
jetzt fragen was kurzfristig und schnell
bedeutet bei der Einführung der PBR 2.0
wenn er 2025 dahinter steht das würde
sagen kurzfristige ummesserung des
Koalitionsvertrages was es auch ein Jahr
gebraucht hat bis nach der Legislatur
ich frage aber eine andere Frage wir
haben als Union die Union und wir als
LINKE haben gemeinsam einen Antrag
gestellt der auf das weht oder das
Finanzministers Lindner Hinweis ich habe
ihn sozusagen vorhin als Steuermann der
Revolution beschrieben jetzt wollte ich
sie tatsächlich mal fragen weil niemand
der koalitionskollegen Kollegen darauf
dass er eingegangen ist wieso haben sie
denn diesen Antrag von uns beiden
abgelehnt weil das tatsächlich doch in
unseren Augen
nicht sein kann dass damit die
pflegepersonalregung wirklich eingeführt
werden kann
na ja gut erstens ist ja mal noch gar
nicht abgestimmt sondern die sind ja
noch zweitens haben sie den nicht
gemeinsam gestellt sondern
unterschiedlich von daher also wir
bleiben sortiere mal erstmal vor aber
ich möchte tatsächlich darauf eingehen
weil natürlich dieser Punkt tatsächlich
zu Irritationen führt und ich denke wir
müssen einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen dass
in einer Regierung alle Ressorts die an
bestimmten Entscheidungen und nicht nur
das eine beteiligt werden wenn
Beschlüsse gefasst werden und von daher
gehe ich davon aus dass es auch in
Zukunft so sein wird alle Ressorts die
betroffen sind werden einbezogen nicht
nur das Finanzministerium und ich möchte
darauf hinweisen dass in Deutschland
die das Krankenpflegepersonal bezahlt
wird von den Krankenkassen und nicht aus
dem Bundeshaushalt und von daher glaube
ich dass es ein hinfeld Nein das ist
überhaupt kein Argument das Argument ist
was was soll denn der Einspruch bedeuten
wie gesagt ich finde man hätte auf diese
Formulierung verzichten können aber sie
steht da drin und sie wird keine
Auswirkungen haben auf die
pflegepersonalbemessung die wir brauchen
denn daraufhin hat die daraufhin gibt es
keinen Einfluss der Bundeshaushalt ist
nicht verantwortlich für die
Finanzierung des Pflegepersonals und das
ist auch gut so
sonst hätten wir in der Frage außerdem
wenn ich erfahre jetzt sitzt da schon
ich wäre jetzt ganz gerne noch darauf
eingegangen welche Begleitmaßnahmen mir
notwendig sein es kann ja sein dass
durch die Einführung erstmal deutlich
wird dass wir zu wenig Personal haben
und deswegen werden wir eine ganze Reihe
von Maßnahmen zum Beispiel die Stärkung
des deutschen pflegerats auch beim
gemeinsamen Bundesausschuss
stärken denn wir werden sehr viel mehr
Pflege qualifizierte Pflege mehr
qualifizierte Pflegekräfte brauchen und
dazu brauchen wir eine gemeinsame
gesellschaftliche Anstrengung und ich
würde mich helfen über mich freuen wenn
Sie uns dabei helfen und unterstützen
würden ich glaube mit diesem Gesetz sind
wir dazu auf einem guten Weg danke schön
wir haben wir legen heute mit diesem
Gesetz den Grundstein für die längst
überfällige Aufwertung der
professionellen Pflege der stationären
Versorger und Deutschland und das ist
gut für den Beruf das ist aber vor allem
auch im Interesse der Menschen in
Deutschland die ins Krankenhaus kommen
die kranken Menschen die es verdient
haben dass wir in Zukunft gute
Versorgung sicherstellen und zwar
gemeinsam als Gesellschaft aber eben
auch als professionelle in die in diesem
Bereich arbeiten die Menschen haben es
verdient sie brauchen diese gute Pflege
und es ist längst überfällig nach so
vielen Jahren des Versagens und des
Ausbleibens dieser deutlichen Zeichen
für eine qualitative Verbesserung der
professionellen Pflege in den letzten
Jahren lassen Sie uns gemeinsam dafür
sorgen und ich habe den Eindruck dass
auch die
Oppositionsparteien bereit sind
mitzuwirken und von daher freue ich mich
auf die Zusammenarbeit
jetzt ist leider meine Redezeit zu Ende
ich hätte gerne noch die Kollegen aber
ich bin auch gehalten dafür zu sorgen
dass man noch ein Stückchen wenigstens
in der verabredeten debattenzeit bleiben
und nicht die Redezeit die in die
Fraktion gewährt hat verdreifachen
Kollege Sorge
[Gelächter]
das Wort hat der Kollege Axel Müller für
die cdu/csu-fraktion die beiden letzten
Redner jetzt in dieser Debatte zum
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz in
der Tat hängt der ganze debattentag etwa
35 Minuten an dieser Stelle die Tonlage
etwas persönlicher geworden ist und
wir haben in der Tat eine sehr
dramatische Situation aktuell auf den
Intensivstationen der Kinderklinik der
Minister hat darauf hingewiesen und es
ist schon fast beschämen dass wir von
6007 Intensivbetten gegenwärtlich nur
367 betreiben können weil viele Orts
einfach das Personal fehlt und es kann
nicht sein dass die schwächsten einer
Gesellschaft die unsere Hilfe bedürfen
die sie Hilfe nicht erfahren können weil
oder obwohl wir so viel Geld ausgeben
das aber auch vielfach verpufft 440
Milliarden sind die Gesamtausgaben über
440 Milliarden im Gesundheitswesen in
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland fast so
viel wie interessante Bundeshaushalt und
zusammengefasst muss man sagen wir
nutzen unsere Potenziale nicht wirklich
effizient wir haben zu viele Häuser auf
dass sich das wenige Personal oder auf
die sich das wenige Personal verteilt
bei enorm gestiegenen Sach- und
Energiekosten und teilweise auch bei
erheblichen Investitionsstau wofür die
länderverantwortlich sind zu Optimierung
soll das hier zu Debatte stehende Gesetz
der Personalbemessung beitragen und ich
habe da so meinen Zweifel die Kollegen
der Unionsfraktion haben unsere Zweifel
auch vorgetragen deshalb will ich dabei
zunächst einmal bewenden lassen im
Gesetzespaket finden sich auch weitere
Änderungen und zwar zu Vergütung der
Krankenhäuser und darauf möchte ich kurz
eingehen
ich bin in der seit über zwölf Jahren im
Kreistag von Ravensburg wir haben
insgesamt sechs Häuser gehabt wir haben
jetzt noch zwei vier haben wir
geschlossen um unser System zu
optimieren und dennoch haben wir
gegenwärtig einen zweistelliges
Millionen Defizit und eine nicht
unwesentliche Ursache ursache dafür sind
einfach die Vergütungen im Krankenhaus
entgeltgesetzt drei Punkte aller Kürze
erstens der Katalog ambulante Leistung
nimmt stetig zu das ist hier bereits
ausgeführt worden die Sektorengrenzen
fallen und die Häuser bieten jetzt auch
immer mehr ambulant zu stationär an also
Hybrid
die damit einhergehenden Verlust deren
stationären Fällen müssen jedoch durch
die hybridiaschies angemessen
ausgeglichen werden und das scheint
gegenwärtig nicht der Fall zu sein
und das geht aber auch für die hier in
diesem Gesetzespaket mit enthaltenen
Tages Behandlungen es ist nicht klar und
nicht eindeutig und nicht auskömmlich
wie diese finanziert werden sollen
unsere Änderungsantrag greift das
deshalb auf zweitens die Grundlage für
die Vergütung ist der basisfall Wert er
wird einmal im Jahr festgelegt kommt es
zu Kostensteigerung die gegenwärtig
hätte damit nicht mehr Schritt es muss
eine Möglichkeit geschaffen werden dass
unter dem Jahr nachverhandelt werden
kann insbesondere Krisenzeiten und das
dritte das sind betriebswirtschaftliche
Grundsätze ganz zum Schluss die werden
nicht berücksichtigt wenn hohe
Fallzahlen in einem Bereich zu weniger
Fixkosten führen und dazu einen Abschlag
gemacht wird dann muss es aber auch
umgekehrt der Fall sein wenn wir weniger
Fallzahlen haben dann müssen diese
weniger falsch sein mindestens dazu
führen dass der Abschlag reduziert wird
auch da lässt er Entwurf oder ist der
Gesetzesvorschlag nichts erkennen und
zum Schluss noch Einsatz zu den sechs
Milliarden die da angekündigt sind für
die Häuser meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren das ist schön und dem
vernehmenach sei eine Aufteilung
beabsichtigt von viereinhalb für die
Energiekosten und anderthalb für die
Sachkosten es ist aber genau andersrum
die Häuser weisen jetzt schon darauf hin
dass die Sachkosten das Problem sind und
da sieht ihr Vorschlag nichts vor oder
ihre Lösung die sie da ankündigen nichts
vor und er sieht auch nichts vor wann
das Geld denn kommen soll und zu welchem
Zeitpunkt und wie konkret es denn
verteilt werden soll löblich letzter
Satz löblich selbstverständlich der
Aufwuchs bei den Zuwendungen der
Geburtshilfe und der Pädiatrie aber so
wie es jetzt ausgestattet ist sie müssen
hier eine verteilen bitte eine weitere
Verteilung weitere verteilungskriterien
nachgearbeitet werden auch das sieht
unser Änderungsantrag vor ich bitte um
Zustimmung danke schön
nun die letzte Rednerin in dieser
Debatte Heike Behrens von der
SPD-Fraktion die gesundheitspolitische
Sprecherin Petra Pau die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin hat hier ein
bisschen
muss ein bisschen Schwung ins Haus
bringen damit hier auch die Disziplin
bei den Redebeiträgen gewahrt bleibt
also die schlussrednerin für das
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
versprochen gehalten die
pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 kommt sie ist
ein wichtiges Instrument zur Stärkung
der Pflege im Krankenhaus und wurde von
einem breiten Bündnis aus der Pflege mit
allem Nachdruck eingefordert die
ExpertInnen von deutschen pflegerart
Verdi und deutscher
Krankenhausgesellschaft erwarten von
diesen bedarfsermittlungsverfahren
entscheidende Verbesserungen für die
Versorgungsqualität im Krankenhaus und
für die Arbeitszufriedenheit der
Pflegeperson darum sorgen wir heute
dafür dass die PPR 2.0 starten kann denn
wir wissen gute Pflege braucht Zeit und
damit auch mehr Personal als aktuell
vorhanden ist
wie viel Personal es auf den
verschiedenen Stationen eines
Krankenhauses konkret braucht das genau
wird mit dem Verfahren nun ermittelt und
zwar von den Pflegefachpersonen selbst
es sind die Praktiker innen die uns
davon überzeugt haben das mit der PPA
2.0 ein Bürokratie Armes Instrument zum
Einsatz kommen das an die vertrauten der
Pflegepersonal Richtlinien von früher
anknüpft und deshalb einfach umzusetzen
ist und deshalb Herr Sorge stimmt es
nicht dass dieses Gesetz die
Beschäftigten belastet sondern nein es
entlastet und genau nein genau das hat
heute der Deutsche Pflegerat in seiner
Pressemitteilung auch so öffentlich
verkündet
gemeinsam mit unseren
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
haben wir den guten Gesetzentwurf im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch besser
gemacht wir sorgen nämlich dafür dass
die PPA 2.0 zukünftig in einem
strukturierten wissenschaftlichen
Prozess weiterentwickelt wird denn es
ist uns wichtig dass die neue
Personalbemessung auch in der
Intensivmedizin für Kinder und
Erwachsene und in den Notaufnahmen
angewandt sowie der notwendige
qualifikationsmix mit abgebildet wird
heute sorgen wir mit der PPA 2.0 für
Einnahmen Bedarf orientierte Pflege in
unseren Krankenhäusern wir gestalten
diesen Prozess ganz bewusst gemeinsam
mit denen die Tag für Tag gute
Versorgung der Patientinnen und
Patienten gewährleisten
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass wir weiter
vor größten Herausforderungen stehen
qualifiziertes Personal für unsere
Krankenhäuser zu gewinnen das zeigt die
aktuelle Krise in den Kinderkliniken auf
dramatische Weise wir haben keinen
bettenmangel wir haben einen
gravierenden Fachkräftemangel und daher
arbeiten wir parallel mit allem
Nachdruck daran die Arbeitsbedingungen
in der Pflege zu verbessern und ganz
konkret das umzusetzen was nötig ist
damit mehr Menschen für diese wertvollen
Berufe in der Pflege begeistert werden
um den Arbeitsalltag und die
Lohnbedingungen weiter zu verbessern und
um Pflegekräfte die ihren Beruf
verlassen haben zurück zu gewinnen als
Koalition der des Fortschritts werden
wir diesen Weg entschlossen weitergehen
und für uns als SPD kann ich versprechen
wir werden weiter alles tun um die
Pflege zu stärken vielen Dank für Ihre
aufmerksam
Heike Behrens zum Abschluss dieser
Debatte wir werden jetzt durch die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin sozusagen das
Abstimmungsprozedere erleben das
genießen war einfach noch mal weil
Freitagnachmittag ist und kurz vor 2
Advent im Krankenhaus so wie zur
Anpassung weiterer Regelungen im
Krankenhauswesen und in der
Digitalisierung der Ausschuss für
Gesundheit empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache
4.708 neu den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf den Drucksachen
3876 und
4232 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
danke wer stimmt dagegen
Anke wir enthält sich danke der
Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung mit den Stimmen der
Koalitionsfraktionen gegen die
cdu/csu-fraktion und die Linke bei
Enthaltung der afd-fraktion angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich
danke der Gesetzentwurf ist mit den
Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen gegen
die Stimmen der cdu/csu-fraktionen und
der Fraktion DIE LINKE bei Enthaltung
der afd-fraktion angenommen
wir kommen zur
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktionen der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache 433
4.733 Entschuldigung wer stimmt für den
Entschließungsantrag
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die
Koalitionsfraktionen wer enthält sich
die afd-fraktion und die Fraktion DIE
LINKE der Entschließungsantrag ist
abgelehnt
Tagesordnungspunkt 34b wir kommen zur
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
des Ausschusses für Gesundheit zum
Antrag der Fraktion der AFD mit dem
Titel
Versorgungssicherheit von
Intensivpatienten verbessern
Intensivpflege in Deutschland stärken
und zukunftssicher machen der Ausschuss
für Gesundheit empfiehlt unter Buchstabe
b seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache
4708 den Antrag der Fraktion der AFD auf
2586 abzunehmen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich niemand die
Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den Stimmen
der Koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion der Fraktion DIE LINKE
gegen die Stimmen der afd-fraktion
angenommen
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
des Ausschusses für Gesundheit zu dem
Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem
Titel
Koalitionsvertrag umsetzen
pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 Einführen der
Ausschuss für Gesundheit empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe c seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache
4708 den Antrag der Fraktionen die Linke
1731 abzunehmen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich die Beschlussempfehlung ist
mit den Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen
der cdu/csu-fraktion und der
afd-fraktion gegen die Stimmen der
Fraktion DIE LINKE angenommen